ici c était un projet qui était
maintenant collaboration que service
d'aménagement des rivières et le
syndicat de rivière locale où les
travaux consistaient à réouvrir des
anciens bras de la rivière pour
améliorer l'état écologique de la
confluence entre le string bar le cours
d'eau qui descendent du massif vosgien
et la fecht
dont le conseil général travaille en
délégation avec des syndicats dans le
but d'aménager des rivières sur diverses
problématiques que ce soit la gestion
des inondations ou des renaturation
comme dans ce cas-ci donc les travaux
sur ce secteur ont été réalisés en
octobre 2012 c'est mon prédécesseur
thomas nussbaumer qui a réalisé l'étude
donc lui il a réalisé l'étude pour
savoir hydrauliquement comment se
passait à la réouverture des bras à
partir de relevés topographiques pour
savoir dans quel sens réalise exactement
les terrassements et et mettre en oeuvre
c'est donc en fait on a réalisé un
travail avec des associations la ligue
pour la protection des oiseaux et les
associations bufo qui s'occupe du suivi
des amphibiens et des reptiles en alsace
où avec eux avant les que les travaux
démarrent on a réalisé un état initial
on a fait un inventaire des différents
groupes donc initialement on avait très
peu d'espèces liés aux rivières aux
zones humides parce que la rivière ne
passait pas sur le site et donc à la fin
des travaux on va à une année après les
travaux on a des espèces de libellules
qui sont apparues qui sont propres aux
rivières avec un voile rivero courante
on a des espèces d'oiseaux aussi qu'ils
sont arrivés parce que le site a été un
peu réouvert on a le martin pêcheur qui
apparut et après en terme de végétation
on a une végétation on va dire classique
des bords de rivières et des zones
humides pendant les travaux n'a
travaillé aussi avec la centre de
réintroduction des loutres du navire où
on a fait la pose de catiches donc 2 on
va dire des nichoirs pour les pour les
loutres des gîtes artificiel pour que
les autres puissent venir s'installer
sur le site parce que c'est une ancienne
zone connue pour la loutre et on a aussi
le castor qui pourraient bénéficier de
ces travaux et qui est présent à
proximité donc qui peut être qu'ils
fréquentent des peut-être déjà le site
les contraintes déjà c'est qu'il y avait
une partie des bras qui était de temps
en temps en haut des anciens bras donc
on a dû reporté à plusieurs reprises les
travaux parce qu'il y avait encore de
l'eau il ya eu aussi on ne fait pas de
travaux pendant la période de
nidification des oiseaux parce qu'il ya
eu des coupes d'arbres qui ont été
faites voilà et puis également quand
pendant la période de reproduction des
batraciens et qu'on avait sur le site
déjà des pontes des ponts de batraciens
donc on n'a pas fait les travaux à cette
période là donc du coup ça nous a fait
faire les travaux en novembre 2013
les équipes qui ont été mobilisés on a
en interne le parc d'intervention en
matériel c'est lui qui a fait les
travaux tout ce qui est terrassement
donc le pim et on a fait aussi
intervenir au niveau des plantations et
des coupes d'arbres la sava section
d'aménagement végétal d'alsace
pour le suivi qu'on va mettre en place
on va continuer cinq ans après les
travaux de voir comment le milieu a
évolué quelles espèces ont pu
réapparaître avec un peu plus de temps
on pense que le milieu aura évolué donc
certainement d'autres espèces auront pu
apparaître ou peut-être que certaines
espèces qui sont apparues juste après
les travaux ne trouveront plus les
conditions nécessaires pour se
développer donc risque de déplacer ou ne
put être sur le site donc c'est pour ça
que en 2017 on refera un nouveau un
travail avec les associations et en
interne aussi d'inventaire pour essayer
de quantifier avec un laps de temps plus
long ce qui a pu se passer sur le site
comment le site a évolué